[Music]
sean is in houston texas hi sean how are
you
hello um i'm doing pretty good i'm
calling because
we're being sued by american express we
were served this weekend the papers we
owe them
we owe them 85 000 we have 50 000
and i'm trying to find out uh do i need
to hire an attorney or should i
try to settle with them for the 50 000
or i have talked to an attorney they
told me it would be
hundred dollars to hire now and i'm just
trying to find out which way to go
okay uh that sounds a little steep to
settle that
and uh how far behind are you
we left we were all paying uh we we last
paid them in july
uh right after you know the cover thing
uh we were on
the world and 85 000 on an amex card
it's a it was a business card and my
husband
decided to do a business deal and
fronted all the material for
a project and that's this yep
so here we go this is why we don't do it
okay i just wanted to learn
i wanted to learn the lesson with you
there ouch i'm sorry i'm sorry you're
facing this
yeah that's a big enough deal i'm not
going to have you settle that on your
own i would get
legal representation i don't think you
found the right legal representation yet
and no you're not bankrupt you have
enough money to settle this amex will do
this
but they are they're skunks they are not
good people
and we deal with them all the time and
you can tell they're lying if their
mouths moving
so you really do need to get legal
representation i think you can settle it
for 50 or less with them if you haven't
paid them since july
try this go to collection bully
collection relief.com that's a group of
attorneys that we recommend for people
that are being bullied by collectors
okay and i think one of them will
probably pick up your case and represent
you for less than that i might be wrong
it might be that
much but okay um okay but if you can
settle 85 for 50 and it costs you five
grand that's still a deal right
that's still a bill yeah it is and sean
i'm proud of you for being proactive
uh because a lot of people would freeze
in the moment and
i'm glad you're being proactive and
acknowledging this for what it is
it is something that needs to be dealt
with absolutely
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five and you're not bankrupt okay so
not picking on her or her husband but um
38 of small businesses use credit cards
to finance their business ideas
and this is where you end up mm-hmm on
the verge of bankruptcy mm-hmm
stop that crap yeah wow organically grow
your business with the cash that the
business creates
and if you can't if you don't have the
money or can't get a big enough deposit
to cover
the project don't take the price don't
do it